it has been eight years since the Syrian
civil war first started over the course
of the conflict about half a million
Syrians are believed to have been killed
and even more have been injured the war
has also triggered a massive refugee
crisis our partners at BBC News have
followed the stories of several Syrian
children as they grow up without parents
and without a real home correspondent
Carolyn Hawley caught up with a few of
them I name is Mustafa the
eight-year-old and his little sister
Dora survived a barrel bomb it destroyed
their family home near Aleppo leaving
only their grandmother to look after
them safe in the cupboard is the
stuffers most precious possession that's
all he has left of his father Ibrahim
who died saving him
his mother was also killed but he
doesn't even have a photo to remember
her Mustafa was so badly injured he
spent a whole year in hospital twice a
week he still comes for physiotherapy
his strong boy is very strong his left
hand doesn't move properly because of a
piece of shrapnel in his brain his hips
were badly broken and one leg is now
longer than the other
Mustafa needs help to dress and wash
[Music]
the challenges Mustafa faces are no less
daunting than when we first met him when
he was five but he's no less determined
the Syrian war has created many must
offers children whose injuries and loss
will stay with them for the rest of
their lives
millions of Syrian children can now only
remember living as refugees many inmates
shift camps with no homes to return to
rah who was born as the conflict began
is also eight since we first met her
life hasn't got any easier have
addictive Jayasuriya leash nor did she
fall for her in a book and she
Babbitt alone no Raja Haram - rah is
often sick she needs her tonsils out but
her family can't afford the operation
her father can't work because his leg
was shattered by a sniper's bullet it
crushes him to see Ross suffer and not
be able to help
[Music]
back in Jordan was tougher as saying his
evening prayers imagine again a big this
Allah Allah it's only recently the most
uh first stop screaming in his sleep but
his grandmother still can't rest she
lies awake she says terrified of what
will happen to him when she's gone
Caroline holy BBC News and man